following breaking news tonight here a
jet crash in a neighborhood in the far
northeast part of the valley
clark county fire confirming the pilot
died in the crash
viewers have been sending in pictures
and videos showing these large plumes of
black smoke
that crash happened on north christie
lane not too far from washington and
nellis
we have team coverage for you tonight
our reporters orco mana and joe muller
both on the scene in different aspects
of what's going on at the crash
but begin tonight with joe moeller
yeah we are waiting to get some more
information about this crash and we're
trying to learn who this pilot is and
whether or not they tried to eject
before this plane had crashed now we
learned some more information about this
plane a short time ago
that it is a dassault aviation mirage f1
aircraft here taking a look here
at christie lane and judson just north
of this location is where a lot of
officials are meeting to discuss this
still a lot of emergency vehicles here
a lot of traffic in this area a photo
was sent to 8 news now courtesy
of taylor grimm even more smoke and
police cars could be seen in video as
well
we spoke with teresa nelson she was
driving in this area and noticed
something odd about that plane flying
over
i was sitting in my car and i heard a
plane go by and then i heard another
plane but it didn't sound normal you
could tell there was something wrong
with it
so i looked at it and it was coming down
very fast and it was
pretty low and the plane was at a tilt
like this and you could tell that he
probably couldn't get juice forces back
up in time
and it just went boom crashed into a
house
i saw the black smoke i got pictures of
that that was crazy because you could
tell there was something wrong with that
plane
it was making it was funny noises
[Music]
now back out here live we're taking
another look at the scene here a lot of
intersections are closed off we spoke to
a number of people who were out here
about this they had similar stories they
saw that plume of smoke
many were worried because an elementary
school is not too far from this location
so
a lot of people were coming out calling
9-1-1 and the power was out in this area
for
quite some time about an hour ago a pio
from metro had come by and told us we
would be getting an update
here soon from the air force so we are
waiting to get some more information
from them so of course
we'll keep you updated reporting live
i'm joe mullen i'll send it back to you
joe thank you there are lots of moving
parts to this investigation emergency
crews have blocked off a
good chunk of that area orco mana
joining us now live near nellis and
kerry with a different vantage point
and some new details about the crash
orco
denise nellis air force base reports
that the plane involved in this crash
is a contractor operated aircraft we're
told it took off from nellis
and then went down around 2 30 this
afternoon where we are is a couple
blocks away
from the crash site but you can see
metro police and other emergency
vehicles
are still blocking the streets in this
area now we want to show you viewer
video
from sam stouts showing the fiery
aftermath of the plane crashes take a
look you can see the plan
the flames and a large plume of black
smoke billowing into the air that could
be seen for miles
witnesses tell us this was a terrifying
situation for the people who live and
work in this area
i spoke to christian mendoza over the
phone he describes what he saw
i just see a bunch of black smoke and it
looked like it had
where it where it crashed it looked like
somebody's yard
and it caught like a trailer on fire
a lot of things i've seen in my life
that's probably
the number one thing that
that scared me
and we're also hearing from officials on
this crash governor steve sisolak
tweeting out
that he is praying for all those
involved in today's incident
especially the men and women of nellis
air force base and senator jackie rosen
saying that she's closely monitoring
this crash back out here live again as
you can see we have
several emergency vehicles blocking the
roads in this area
again we're being told by the faa that
the faa and the ntsb
are also investigating this crash now
the ntsb does not normally
investigate military incidents but we're
told because a civilian
was flying the aircraft that the ntsb is
involved in the investigation
as joe said we are awaiting an update to
learn more about what exactly happened
so be sure to stay with eight news now
both on air and online for the latest
developments for now reporting live orgo
mana 8 news now